[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
this is uh a rough cut
of uh one of the new tracks on our new
album sunspin's new album
anyway yeah it was really fun making the
album and uh we're still making the
album we've got a lot of great um
musicians uh adding to the songs and
we're getting harmonies and doing all
that stuff now so it's really fun the
album for sunspin will come out
hopefully in the next couple months and
there'll be cds and albums and things
available i'm i i think you could also
go to sunspin.com
and you can get tickets for our show um
well actually we already did our show so
maybe the next time i'll give you that
information but go to sunspin.com for um
if you want to zoom me if you want to
get cool merch uh sunspin mugs sunspin
hats also the inside of you online store
blah blah blah you get a bunch of merch
there but uh welcome ryan thank you for
uh being here with me i feel uh like i'm
in like i'm floating on a cloud that was
very dreamy what that song yeah you
liked it yeah oh thanks man yeah i
played it for you earlier
it's a synthy thing i like the synth
right yeah it's synth yeah it's the
synth of floaty yeah it's floaty i like
it too it takes me back to the 80s and
that's i sort of want to make songs that
are like feel like the 80s or the 90s or
a little bit of now but retro
that kind of feel uh thanks for taking
the time to be
um to join me to listen to me to uh
hopefully enjoy this podcast we've got a
great one today she's never been on the
podcast before but i love her she was uh
clark kent's mom on smallville and we
got to work together a little bit and i
adore her annette o'toole she's here
today so i hope you guys enjoy it uh
also if you want to join patreon uh
patreon really helps the podcast so if
you really like it you want to support
the podcast and give back go to
patreon.com inside you p-a-t-r-e-o-n
patreon.com inside of you i'll send you
a message after you join there's
different tiers i send merch i write
little notes
so i thank you
and um that's really all i have to say
is there anything else we need to talk
about ryan uh we're ryan is there
anything we need to talk about
i'm kidding well now
now now
uh
hey i hope you guys are doing well um
our handles by the way are at inside you
podcast on uh instagram and facebook at
insideyoupod on the twitter
um it really helps um you know i've
talked about this but when you follow us
you write a review and keep listening
and spread the word that's that's pretty
much i have to say it every episode and
i'm saying it i i say it because you
know i'd like people to listen like more
people to listen i think we have a good
show here and i hope you enjoy it too so
without further ado why don't we just
get into it why don't we get inside of
the lovely annette o'toole
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience how many podcasts do you do you
think i've done
two this is the second one i did i know
you did ileana douglas's that's not a
podcast it wasn't a podcast well it's a
long time ago maybe they didn't call it
that then maybe it was maybe it was kind
of interview many years ago it was right
after john hurd died i remember because
we talked about john you did a movie
with john heard yeah cat people cat
people
right yeah was that where you obviously
were close with him yeah you know i
hadn't seen him in a while but i loved
john we did cat people we did at outer
limits in vancouver first time i ever
worked in vancouver are we shooting i
mean yeah are we we're just we're just
talking
because i'll talk more importantly no
you don't have to talk importantly we're
just fun candid
whatever you know well anyway yeah i i
adored john and uh he went through he
was a very complicated guy and um i just
always felt really
like he was my brother because i never
had a brother and then but i'm not that
close
but you felt like you wanted to help him
you wanted to
talk to him what was it about him that
was a w word did you just use you said
he was not complex but complicated
complicated there was something really
like little lost boy about him
um and he's a brilliant guy and and he
just had so much going for him but he
had really a lot of demons but i
remember we were in new orleans doing
cat people
and uh
he had just come out of a i guess
a marriage or an affair or something
with with
margo kidders i don't know he was he was
not in a good place
and so he was he was drinking a lot and
um another uh frankie fazen who was an
actor also in cat people he and i had
gone out to dinner and we were on the
trolley going back to our hotel and we
saw this guy just like asleep kind of
passed out on the park on the bench
and it was we realized it was john so he
got out we got him into the trolley got
him but i don't even know if he was
staying at that hotel how old is he at
this time at this point he was like
early 30s and he was just passed out
drunk
yeah i hate to talk about it but because
he's gone now and then every he kind of
was very
you know vocal about his his demons and
issues and stuff but anyway after that
he got great he got he got a lot better
and he worked and he was and he was
great in that movie
yeah in cad people we had such a good
time together and um do you see that a
lot like in your career have you seen a
lot of you know actors or people that
you've talked to just
kind of go down that path of darkness
and drinking and you're like
there's only one other one i can think
of right now who who i was
you know i had a not a relationship with
but a working relationship with tim
was
mcintyre
very troubled he was
um
god what he played uh george jones when
i did tell me when that
man yes and he was
not in good shape he was a daughter a
son of uh jeanette nolan and tim
mcintyre i mean uh john mcintyre who's a
great actor
um that probably says a lot too when
your dad's an actor yeah and then right
right away you think oh following the
footsteps and yeah i don't know he was
he was kind of
and he's also gone he was he's passed
away a while ago
um but no i i maybe because i don't look
for that if it's very very apparent i i
i see it and
you know
have to deal with it but it's uh i don't
know a lot of people who who went that
way did you stay away from that have you
ever been a drinker did you ever get
involved in the drugs and stuff you seem
like you wouldn't like knowing you i
don't picture it but i'd love to hear
the dirt if you ever no i have no dirt i
i didn't drink at all for a long time
and it never
it never i never liked hard liquor i
never liked the taste of it i love the
smell of it my grandfather always drink
a big glass of bourbon when you come
home from work from work and my
grandmother would have the ice ready for
him and then she'd pour this huge
tumbler
every night yeah every night and i
stayed with him a lot because my mother
was a dance teacher right and so and my
dad was working and he come pick me one
of them would come pick me up but
i was with them a lot all by myself and
um
that's where i started baking and my
whole like home economics side of my
life uh but grampy would come home and i
would serve him his drink get him his
slippers
and we'd watch the news together
and uh he was diabetic so i had to learn
how to cook how old are you at this
point
then i was really little i was
six or seven six or seven given
grandpa's burger yeah what a treat it
was from texas he knows what we did what
did he call you had to have a nickname
neddy i knew it see say something the
whole daddy got me my bourbon no he
wasn't like what what was he oh no he
was very elegant he's matty no not like
english it wasn't english why did i
think english he was just he was just a
great guy anyway so i would give him his
drink and so i always loved the smell of
it and it reminded me of him but i
wouldn't drinking it was like drinking
turpentine to me it wasn't until i was
doing
uh right before smallville i was doing
this show called uh the huntress and i
was the lead of this this cable show and
i was starting to have heart
palpitations because i was just i mean
being number one on it on
our show is is crazy it's i've never
worked that hard and you're playing a
tough role too right yeah very active
running around as a bounty hunter bounty
hunter right and jordana spiro was my
daughter we were running all over the
place and busting people and um
so here's the side sidebar right um
we'll get back to the alcoholism get
back there's no i know because i finally
started drinking wine because my doctor
told me you know for your palpitations
to drink grape juice and it was so sweet
somebody said why don't you just drink a
little glass of wine because
it's like oh
i really love this does it help yes it
really helps oh my gosh so you'd have a
glass of wine every night one glass yes
sometimes more than that right okay so
that's all i drink i don't like hard
liquor at all i've tried i've tried to
drink martinis and stuff but i don't
like them
um there's a sidebar there's a sidebar
sidebar um yes
michael and my michael and chris guest
and harry sure were doing this acoustic
version of of all their music called
unwigged unplugged
and we were traveling all over with tiny
little mini tour the first time i'd ever
done anything like this and i was the
backup singer for like a couple of songs
and i would i was basically wendy just
kind of traveling on the bus with them
and ironing shirts and going out to
dinner and he was staying up all night
it was so much is that bus stop wendy
but maybe
that's a new play i'm gonna right right
but anyway so i was just having the best
time so we that we're playing some we're
they are playing this indian casino
somewhere in on the east coast i can't
remember the name of it
um
you know every it was packed everybody
was there to see it and so
joel mchale is there because he was
either playing another room or he was
coming in after us or something he came
to see them because of course he loves
spinal tap like most people
and so um he said you know
you gave me my first job in l.a i said
what
he said the huntress i was quickie the
clown
michael and i wrote one episode of the
huntress called springing tiny or james
riemar who is in it getting him out of
jail
you should have james remar on your show
you know him are you kidding can you
hook that up yes dude i love romeo are
the warriors and his his we were in 48
hours together 48 hours so he was he
gans
yeah did he play games i never watched
the movies you were great in that though
thank you i don't remember the names of
the characters like that so anyway so uh
um
what was i telling you james remar so
james remore yeah but but then joel
mchale john mccain so
anyway the huntress you cast in the hunt
james was in it in the show with me
called and he was playing tiny bellows
so anyway we michael and i wrote this
episode called springing tiny and uh
there was always like this cold open
kind of thing where we'd be going out
and getting uh
we were the bounty hunters getting
somebody it wasn't related to the rest
of the show it was just this opening
thing teaser kind of thing so we had
this guy who was all painted up like a
clown and he was at a kid's party and we
were going after him for for not paying
his child support
jordan and i so there's a whole thing
where i'm like jumping on his back
and and i never saw this man without
makeup
he was uh when i came onto the set he
was in full blown
and it turned out to be joel mchale and
that was his first you didn't know i had
no idea but he wasn't he wasn't like
joel mchale that we know right handsome
yeah he actually took the whole couch
ryan couldn't my engineer ryan here
couldn't sit down joel was sprawled down
on the couch comfortable as hell we had
a great report he was he's a great guy
he is such a nice really special i could
see why people like him yeah he's just a
likable guy we did something a couple
years ago or a few years ago called a
stupid and feudal gesture about the life
of doug kenny i played doug kenny's
mother and that was uh will forte and he
played chubby chase which was ironic
since he had
a lot of we worked with yeah we talked
about that that went viral did it he
when he talked about chevy i think he
got like a million hits or something
yeah it was pretty crazy he's awesome i
i love him did you ever work with chevy
chase no i never missed have you ever
never met him no no and it's weird
because i've i worked with marty short
and i steve martin and that the the the
class
crossed my heart yeah and with martin
short you made out with martin short oh
my god you'd have sex with well fake sex
kind of kind of yeah
what was that like by the way
it was fantastic the best thing about
that movie was that it it was shot
almost like a play
because it was mostly just the two of us
and there were some bookend scenes but
it was mostly just the two of us in this
apartment and so we just do it in order
which is so rare you hardly ever get to
shoot anything in in sequence right
and i just adored him and i just think
the world of him and anytime i see him
it's like just
i'm sure he comes to some of those shows
like when christopher guest and michael
mckee and your husband are playing he'll
show up i'm sure steve martin has showed
up you know i don't remember seeing
those two guys really yeah i see him in
new york when i'm um
steve martin wrote this wonderful um
show called bright star he wrote the
music for it and um edie oh my god i'm
so bad you're married to paul simon edie
raquel mikhail raquel ricky brickhell
raquel raquel it's a tough name well
it's not a tough name you remember the
song the song her hit songs
well i remember
one that they wrote for the show that i
sang on because sun's gonna shine again
really yeah
sun is gonna shine again sun's gonna
shine again sun is gonna shine again the
sun's gonna shine again
um
i love it it's a wonderful song and so
anyway i i didn't do the show i did the
uh the workshop of it right
um and so but i'd met steve a couple of
times and he's he's a very interesting
man and he's very sweet but but marty's
like you know because we had such a he's
just out there
he's he's just he's the best and have
you watched uh only murders in the
building not yet oh it's great is it
good ryan it's amazing i loved it it's
really
the music in that show oh my god the
music is amazing
what kind of music it's it's
it kind of feels like the beginning of
you know a masterpiece mystery but then
it go it's very new york sounding and
urban it's it's it's great i'm i'm so
sorry that i can't remember the man's
name who wrote the music and i follow
him on twitter he's got a long name that
i can't pronounce but i want to get into
the music because you really weren't
heavily into music until
we'll get into that i want to get into
that with about michael and the whole 9
11 attacks and all those things well
there was that old story that old story
it's a great story
inside of you is brought to you by sofi
you know with all the jargon ryan flying
around it's hard to understand what the
heck is going on how to figure out how
to start investing
you know
getting your money right is easier with
sofi the first investing platform to
offer stocks etfs automated investing
and cryptocurrency 2 all in one app so
if i just truly this app is so easy to
navigate through and work through easier
than any other app i've been
privy to and
anything easy is good for me that's why
so far the sofi app is so pleasant to
work with whether you're eager to get
started with investing or you already
know the ropes and want to diversify
your portfolio sofi has your back no
commissions on trading stocks and etfs
plus no account fees or hidden fees use
fractional shares that start as low as
five dollars to buy brand name stocks
even if you don't have a couple grand
line around complimentary financial
planners are ready to help with any
questions whether you're stuck on where
to start or need help deciding what to
do next save for retirement with
traditional roth and sep iras get
hands-on with active investing or let
sofi's number one ranked automated
investing tool
robo advisor take the stress out of
building and managing a diversified
portfolio by doing it for you
cut through the jargon and make
investing easier with sofi visit
sofi.com inside to learn how you can win
up to one thousand dollars in stock when
you open an account
that's sofi.com
inside brokerage and active investing
products offered through sofi securities
llc member finra
sipc all investments involve risk
including the loss of principal past
performance does not guarantee future
results or future performance
inside you is brought to you by shopify
um boy shopify has saved me and um
in many ways uh you know when you want
to sell merch when you want to have
somewhere where people can go to and and
buy things
there's nowhere else to go i haven't
heard of any other place actually it's
just shopify is all i know and they make
it so easy to
check out what's selling uh if you're
out of something um it's so easy to
operate and i'm not good with this stuff
but shopify has really worked for me
it's fantastic shopify listen to this
it gives entrepreneurs the resources
once reserved for big business so
upstarts startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility believe me this podcast
started out selling very few things
and uh you know i mean maybe an item or
two and now i
today we're selling
i don't even want to say the number but
we're doing really well i mean we we
sell a lot of products and uh people
keep you know the demand is up and you
see the demand and you see
um what sells and what sells well and
it's so easy like mine shopify powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale you can reach customers
online and across social networks with
an ever growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond
more than a store shopify grows with you
this is possibility powered by shopify
go to shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside right now
shopify.com
inside
i want to go back to houston okay when
you were kind of houston is that a song
houston houston yep going back to
houston
houston
houston you got it that's pretty much
the whole was that it yeah you just keep
saying that what was it like i mean were
your
were your parents very present in your
life yes well i'm an only child
and they desperately wanted children
they couldn't have them for about
six or seven years and they were in the
process of adopting when my mother
finally became pregnant with me and she
said the whole time she was pregnant she
said i thought it was a dream i couldn't
believe it was really going to happen i
wanted it so bad and she said man i
wanted a girl so badly i knew it was
going to be a boy
so she got all her wishes without really
hoping for them and i my mother's still
with us going strong at 96. 96. yeah she
still dances she's a tapped was a tap
teacher and still dances she's she was
dancing you started dancing at three is
that right
i mean three years old i wish somebody
would have had me singing or dancing at
three years old my parents didn't
believe in me at all so they didn't they
just like try to get through school try
not to get too many s
no use do you remember in school when i
went to school we had s's for
satisfactory used for unsatisfactory and
then stood for
nada nada but i used to get a lot of use
michael's behavior is unsatisfactory
you can understand that though
absolutely i'm off the wall a little bit
yeah and you're interesting and there
are a lot of kids who are really smart
and and not interested in what's going
on you know they're they're bored by
yeah i think that's what it was i was
really bored unless i had a really
engaging teacher someone who really took
the time and made the the course
interesting and told stories and
then i was you know and then when you
got were you were you into drama and i
started doing drama like late in high
school at the end and i finally got into
play my senior year and that but i was
always a nervous wreck i was like i
still am to this day i still get the
nerves i still get the yeah anxiety and
it's not fun i always hate it i was like
is there a pill that could just take
this all away and make me super
confident like that movie with
uh
what's his name limitless limitless he
just takes a pill and so you know yeah
uh that would be awesome what i mean do
you get nerves oh yes not as
i've been doing a lot of theater in the
last since smallville ended that would
give me even more thought because i did
a lot of theater and i remember that's
even harder yeah well it's just that
it's it's so immediate you know if
you're doing a movie you can at least go
again but but this is like you're there
and you have to come up with it but i
i'm less
it's always an issue and especially
around the first preview once the first
preview happens because you get like two
or three weeks of previews normally if
you're on broadway you get like months
right so by that time it's like oh i
know how to do this and and then by the
time opening night comes it's almost
like
you know you've got it down
but um
lawrence olivier had terrible stage
fright that's why he's at the end he
didn't do theater anymore and he had
been you know
that was what he was known for one of
the biggest yeah
wow
it's amazing it makes you feel good when
you hear that he had you know
he had he suffered from that and a lot
of people do but a lot of people talk
about it and i don't know how much i
believe it because i think well you have
anxiety but you don't get anxiety like
me
are you the kind of person who
before you're filming
before you start before they say action
you're like in your head and you're like
no
never
because you never seem like that i was
always believe it or not intimidated but
always because i had this profound
respect for you
and when you were on set i was like
it it i don't know if it calmed me but i
was i forced myself to be more calm i go
i want to impress and that oh i don't
want but i remember saying all these
lines and doing this part and i was just
like i just you know and that's a real
actress and she's done it all and i i
want to impress her i remember well i
was impressed i i was very impressed i
was like you were fantastic
and you and john together especially
john so just amazing great yeah john and
i are still close i haven't talked to
him in a while but um i love him and you
know we see each other yeah he's the
best we'll get into that i want to get
into that but like so growing up you had
two parents that just were they always
like i love you i whatever you do you
can't go wrong we
respect you we are there for you pretty
much
i mean i don't understand that well see
i didn't know anything else i was lucky
because i i desperately wanted a sibling
but but
i really didn't i really loved being the
only one and i had cousins who lived
around the corner from me so we'd be
together all day and then i'd go home at
night and have all the attention yeah
yeah and my dad was fantastic because he
would come home and um
and i'd get these little magazines in
the mail you know um not well i got
highlights but another one um
god i can't remember the name of it
there was one called calling all girls
which was later but before that oh
humpty dumpty humpty dumpty humpty
dumpty magazine the magazine i didn't
know did you know that well it's so old
my god i'm so much older than you guys
no not that much but it it
it was great because they would have
activities and puzzles and things you'd
cut out and construct in this magazine
and i loved it and i would get it and my
dad would come home and it's like he he
wouldn't he'd just sit down with me
immediately and do stuff he was just
so hands on yeah and you know i i don't
know if you know i have this lifelong
you know obsession with knitting and
textiles and stuff and he
i started the first thing i got was a
little loom a little pot holder loom
like every kid gets and uh every kid
well you know a lot of girls get it yeah
and i loved it and then they got me a
real like hand loom that has the warp
and you know it has the shuttle and you
weave in it and it came all you know all
set up for you to make a little scarf so
i did that and once that was done i
i i didn't know how to put it on again i
didn't know how to put the warp on and
my dad who was an engineer as a
mechanical engineer didn't know either
there was no internet to find these
things out and he didn't have time to go
the library so he just figured it out
and i remember it being strung all
across the living room these little tiny
almost threads and because he was just
so dedicated to to
to me and helping me do what i wanted to
do and that's how they always were
whatever i wanted
i was encouraged in the arts right
because my
he wasn't but
my my mother um designed the costumes
for and she and her sister owned this
big dancing school in houston and um
so they'd have a big show every year and
they would design the costumes as well
as teach the dances and pick out all the
music and all that stuff so you learned
probably a lot about costuming and all
these other things not that much about
costuming but but certainly about
putting a show together and music and
things like that and dance and so but my
dad was always there helping like
constructing things that you know a
background piece they wanted you know
he'd make it out of you know
pipe cleaners and whatever you know he
would just construct he was always
involved in it and he would love to
watch my mother sew my mind is a great
seamstress and she he would sit and help
her and you know do the patterns with
her they were they were um
they were together from the time they
were 11 and 12. what yeah they lived
around the corner from one another
although he was just a friend he would
just come and hang out at my my mother's
house because he just loved me i hope so
at 11 years old yes you better be a
friend well it wasn't like you know it
was just he was just this kid who
they liked he was this funny kid who
lived around the corner and then he went
off when he was 17 he went after world
war ii he joined the navy and went off
and he came back and my mother said he
he could he was a smoker she said his
hand was shaking so much he couldn't
light a cigarette because he was in the
boiler room
and they would lock them in during
battles and so that they couldn't do
anything but shovel coal or do whatever
they had to do and there was no escape
so you so
anyway he came home for a little bit and
they sent him right back out and because
the war was still going on
and um so that's when she decided she
was going to marry him
how old was she then she was
was she was 16 if he was 17 so they
didn't get married till she was 20. she
just turned 20. my grandparents did the
same thing they didn't get married the
same they knew each other since they
were like 14. and they ended up getting
married he just passed away two years
ago and she just seems like lost i
remember you talking about your
grandfather a lot yeah he's he's the
best yeah biggest role model for me i
mean and it reminds me your father
reminded me of my grandfather because he
had when it came to me
he had endless energy he gave me
attention like no other he would be
interested in me he wouldn't make me
feel stupid he'd make me feel smart he'd
explain things to me
uh he just he would go out and play ten
whatever i wanted to do it was just like
oh my god i just loved having but i
didn't get to see him a lot but you had
that guy all the time i did i was very
very lucky that's brilliant i really
envy that and when did he pass 2016. and
i was not here i was in edinburgh
scotland doing a play
and how did you deal with that it was
really it was the last three and i i was
going for three weeks edinburgh festival
was this big thing they do every year
and it's mostly comedians and and music
big
magic shows and things but there are
some some big
um dramatic plays and i was doing this
play called hamlet in bed it's a
two-hander with this wonderful actor
named michael lawrence who wrote it and
so we had done it at the rattlestick
theater in new york the year before and
so it was a big deal about doing a
skimmed down version of it because you
can only go like not even quite an hour
at these shows because they go one rep
to the other in these venues that they
have
so uh my dad was really ill
and um i was going to be gone for three
weeks
and it was one of those situations where
he could go tomorrow he could stay
another year we were not really sure
never know and he had worked in scotland
he loved scotland
and
by this time he wasn't as
um
he he he'd had everything wrong with him
he'd had strokes he'd had cancer he'd
had heart attacks he had pretty much his
lungs were he's on oxygen the last two
years of his life so you've had a lot of
phone calls you had a lot of phone calls
saying hey you might want to get down
here
yes right so i anyway i went because
i committed to this play i really wanted
to do it and
anyway so i went and three days before i
was done he they called me and he had
passed and so um how do you get through
the next three days
i i
it was it was hard
michael lawrence said do you want to
leave and i said no he he he always the
main thing you taught me was to finish
what you start you know if you can make
a commitment you honor your commitment
so i thought
also he wanted to be buried in houston
and we this was in it he died in l.a
so i knew that it wasn't like i have to
get home for the funeral right it was
getting ready and it and we'll get him
there you know it'll it'll we'll arrange
it all so i knew it wasn't immediate
that i had to be home so anyway i i
finished it i i somehow did it and uh
the hardest part was was the flying home
because i had to go through
um
i had to go through i had to stop
somewhere i can't remember where changed
planes yeah and then before i wasn't a
direct flight from edinburgh and your
mind just wasn't there yeah i was just
like i was just
like wow
yeah
yeah so that was weird but um yeah
so that was a tough time
it was tough but it was
everybody has a tough time you know
there's never any one way it goes that
it's easy yeah i know so
anyway cheese
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than an
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
inside of you listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better h-e-l-p dot com
slash inside get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
inside
inside of you is brought to you by
nissan
the future will be great
but today is just as incredible meet
nissan's most advanced lineup if you
can't get enough adrenaline there's the
all-new 400 hp nissan z or for your
off-road adventures check out the
all-terrain nissan frontier if you're
more of a spontaneous road trip type
person hop in the nissan pathfinder and
for something more electric there's the
stylish nissan aria so let's enjoy the
ride 2023 aria and z not yet available
for purchase expected availability this
spring for 2023 z and this fall for 2023
aria
death i mean you know losing my grandpa
that was one of the biggest losses i've
ever had that's true truthfully that was
but he died of alzheimer's so it was a
slow
slow process and it felt like i was
losing bits of him every year oh that's
so hard it was terrible but you had him
along i had him a long time i was very
very lucky and you want them to live
forever that's right and you know i hear
his voice i talk like him sometimes yeah
i'll go you know he always mike what are
you doing what is this you're such a nut
he would call me a nut
what are you doing with this how old are
you what are you
but um
from indiana no no no he's from new york
he's a new yorker yeah him and my
grandmother
from the bronx oh my whole family is
really from new york and then my dad got
a job transfer when i was like 10 to
indiana
and so i grew up in the southern indiana
a jew no less i mean you know it wasn't
that bad i mean there were a couple
people in my and my sister when my
sister went to high school that would
throw a quarter down the hallway and say
fetch it jew but overall what overall i
never experienced like i never
experienced that but she did
oh is she older she's older oh my god
like five years i never experienced that
although
oh i every once i would get this i'd get
something and i go well i'm a jew and
then they go
no
shut up like no rosenbaum it's rosebomb
you're not a jew
i'm like yeah i am they couldn't it was
like the most incredulous thing that
they'd ever heard
that i was a jew wow but you know i
didn't i don't know maybe
certain people i don't know it wasn't as
bad as my sister had it
but it wasn't you know
probably wasn't fun for her oh my god
you know but when did you know that hey
i want to be an actress i want to what
was it
i was in uh do a musical comedy i wanted
to be a dancer i wanted to be gwen
verdin who i don't know if people know
gwen burton is i don't mean but that's
okay she was an amazing she was a the
first lola damn yankees
she um
she was in chicago she was the first um
is it velma is it's film like roxy she's
first roxy roxy in uh chicago and she
was kind of like someone you really yeah
she was married to bob fosse
um if you saw the movie about bob fosse
that was on a couple years ago um
she uh
she's very prominent in that anyway um
that's that she was my idol and i i
because i grew up in a dancing school i
just always thought that's what i would
do so we came out to l.a and i was 13
and i was doing dancing and studying
dancing and stuff and i got an agent and
they said you know you really should
we're sending you out on these
you know acting interviews you should
take an acting class
so i really had a chip on my shoulder
about it i thought i don't need that i
just want to sing and dance
and um
i was going a lot of you know dance
auditions and stuff so um
i i went to a few acting classes and it
just i didn't didn't speak to me and
then i went to this acting class uh um
led by robert allen stein
who
was a fantastic character actor he was
one in north by northwest with cary
grant he's one of the two guys who
kidnapped kerry oh yeah yeah yeah i just
watched that yeah he's the one with the
hat yeah and uh not the one who um is
the gardener he's the he's the other one
right and i've seen him since and so
many things god i just saw him but you
loved him i loved him and i loved what
he was saying and how he was approaching
it and i'm kidding as i was sitting
there i thought
i started thinking
i want to be this is what i want to do
this is what i want to do why did i
think that this was not this is amazing
and it's a long career and so i had the
an opportunity that that not a lot of
actors have to to make a choice
i had gotten i i was about to turn 18
like in the next two weeks i got a lead
dancing role in a in a big show that was
going to be at the ahmanson theater or
dorothy chandler one of them amundsen i
guess
and uh and i got an episode of gunsmoke
and so guns smoke they conflicted and
you did gunsmithing and i did i chose my
mother said you've gotta you've gotta
make the decision it's your choice did
your dad chime in like i like gun smoke
i'm a fan i think no he would never
chime in but i think he was pleased with
my choice yeah um so i did the unsmoke
yeah and and i i realized that i've been
on
two of the longest running shows ever
gun smoke and law order
wow also nashville bridges and grey's
anatomy grey's anatomy it's gone 18
years of nash bridges you've done yes
you played his wife right i played his
first wife his first one two wives all
right i was the first one was he fun to
work with
don johnson
he was great to work with really he yeah
well i've known him a long time he and
my one of my very my boyfriend bruno
kirby who i was with her eight years
they had done a movie together called
the harrod experiment
um which is where don met melanie
through her mother tippy hundred who was
in um
the harrod experiment
so uh i knew them i mean i would go
you're like almost royalty well i just
know i've just been around so well i
mean it's just kind you know you've
worked with a lot of gyms so
i'm really lucky and and i just
i'm tickled by it too you know i i just
i i still i'm not over the the um
excitement of just being part of this
world you still love acting oh i love
acting more than i've ever loved acting
why
i just
maybe now that you know i i had my
children and they're now off and
everything and so my focus is is on
primarily on my work you know michael
too but he's he's the same way i am it's
like we we can't imagine retiring
and it's nice now because i don't have
as much competition for roles all these
other women you know decided i don't
want to do this anymore this is stupid
they bow out well yeah because they're
smart they they
you know they say i want my life i want
to be able to do what i want to do when
i want to make an appointment i want to
get a dog so you're taking all the rolls
well yeah i am taking all the rules
all those juicy mother grandmother roles
now
uh no but i'm i'm really lucky i'm i'm
on the show that shoots in vancouver
again i'll never leave vancouver um
that's where we did smallville yes uh
called virgin river
yeah it's just just happening right it
no we just finished our fourth season
fourth season yeah there's so many
[ __ ] sh that's just say f-bomb sorry
about that you get safe bombs i don't
really you don't really i've never heard
you say oh my god i say it all the time
i'm really saying this is ridiculous i
have to stop doing it can you say one
f-bomb for me no i'll bleep it i'll i'll
throw it in somewhere when you release
it wait
that would be great so you're getting
roles you love acting now and you've got
this rejuvenation of like yeah this what
a cool thing and i get to go to new york
we have an apartment in new york so i
get to go there and they hire us as
locals so that's nice because there's a
lot that shoots in new york yeah did you
ever experience like i'm sure you did
being a woman in this industry being hit
on being taken advantage of did that
happen a lot to you i maybe i was so
stupid i didn't pick up on it i was
really really naive
really yeah i'd have producers call me
at home and say you want to come to
vegas for the weekend i said well can i
bring my boyfriend
i'd say that and they go no they'd say
no that would you really that's just i
said well why the gate's the whole
i had no
idea i think that's what they were i
just said oh they like me
they want to put me in a show
no
you never in your whole career had any
feeling moment where you're like this
guy's
perv i had one you did
yes and i can't say who it is although
he's passed away very recently he was a
director right who who expected me i it
was a meeting in a hotel room and that
was not unusual right you go to
somewhere and meet because because they
he was from out of town they'd go to you
know they'd have a nice suite or
something you go meet them but you know
you've gone to casting um couches nut
cows and couches you know meetings yes
and because the people are out of town
right yeah and so they have it at the in
a room at the hotel so that to me it
wasn't weird and i knew the person who'd
set it up is totally on the level and
but i walk in and it's like
you know get
come over here you know
you know it was like oh my god and
you're like no no the thing that upset
me most was i thought oh
he really doesn't want to cast me in
this movie
i get it right it didn't it hurts it
hurts it was like oh this is what i'm
here for how dare he and so i told the
the person who'd set it up and he he was
shocked he couldn't believe it i had it
happen to me believe it or not you don't
hear about male stories very often
i just moved to new york i was a young
actor
and this guy
he was one of the most important
artistic directors at a i won't say the
name of the place
like uh not
circle in the square not that one but
something like you know okay
and i just met and we were just talking
and laughing he's like oh you know what
you should come with me to this uh to
this dinner tonight you should
absolutely come
and i didn't think anything of it and i
went with them and um
[Music]
who who was the father uh jerry's father
in seinfeld
jerry
stiller jerry stiller and anne mirra
yeah they were there ah i ended up
dancing with ann murray oh my hours and
hanging out with jerry and just a blast
and it was like wow i'm a year into new
york having
and
you know
we we left and we're walking in my my
house was my apartment where i was
staying was right there and he's like i
go oh yeah
if you want to drink or something you
know whatever
not thinking
he was gay
i didn't think that i didn't i just this
nice guy he's taking me out let's have a
beer i don't i'm like 24.
and we went up there
and he kind of made a little pass at me
and like oh
oh no i'm not i'm not gay i mean some
people have thought that too but i'm not
um you know
so sorry but everything's cool and he's
like oh yeah okay absolutely fine
and we finished the drink and he never
returned any of my calls again never and
he was like a big wick who like was
telling me oh there's this part in this
and there's a part in this and there's
and
after he found out that i wasn't you
know
he just completely shut me down so i
know that feeling of god going oh
i thought he yeah was gonna give me a
chance and if i hadn't accepted it i'd
still have a chance at being maybe a
part of the right professional world you
know but you just you're not thinking
that way
yeah because you just
you're my mind wasn't there at all i
just wanted to work i wanted to act yeah
that that could get you emotional i can
get you upside pretty quickly yeah but
it was it you know but you're lucky it
only happened like really once yeah
maybe a couple other times i don't know
i wasn't aware of it i don't think about
it and i now i wish i i had been more
more aware of these things you know
because i hear about these women's
stories and they're heartbreaking and
horrible and right
you know and i i just feel so lucky that
i just
maybe they just thought well she's so
stupid she's not picking up on this will
we just go to the next person who
right you know smarter and more aware
jesus
seeing your face right now
i really i i it's
what tell me
no i just i just felt really
maybe two because i was uh
raised catholic and and very
you know like this but but it wasn't
even that it was
i don't know i'm not saying anything i
hear you i hear you
when you did
a movie like superman 3
were you thinking i'm going to be i'm
part of this franchise this is going to
be a huge movie i'm working with all
these people this is going to be great
that kind of feeling
it was really exciting to get to work
with richard lester and chris mm-hmm
how was that working with christopher he
was fantastic he was
so kind because i was coming in
i i think i would i think they were just
really angry with margo kidder because
she was
causing them some grief i don't know how
or why and she's been the sweetest you
know she came to smallville and she was
so sweet but even then because i had
like a couple of scenes with her that we
shot in one day it wasn't easy and she
was incredible she was so welcoming
and she was friends with richard pryor
and and she introduced me to him and he
was so kind to me and just we sat on the
set and taught and he was so sweet
really yeah what a great moment yeah he
was amazing i remember we were in um
calgary and that was smallville that was
the the small always canada yeah
canada's always smallville
um and so i was there and it was all
that we're on it's a parade or something
going on i saw the movie one time when
it first came out so i don't remember a
lot but
it it i was on a
like a parade dais kind of thing and
he's up there dressed up like a general
richard pryor
um and so in between texas we just sat
and talked he just want to know about
like just a normal guy fun guy he was
asking me stuff like you're asking me
about my family and and my life and and
i was getting ready to get married and
um
we talked about that anyway he was just
lovely
so um but chris reeve when i got so i
was kind of like a um
they wrote this part of lana because
they didn't have lois lana lang yeah
so i uh i i got there and i had just
finished doing
a play i think i would just finish doing
no i was doing 48 hours at the same time
i just finished 48 hours and i got on a
plane got over there and immediately
like was taken to wardrobe and it was
just this whirlwind i mean it didn't
just happen overnight yeah yeah really
fast and met richard lester and and he's
like and i have this first scene and
it's all but but chris reeve invited me
to his home and he was had
his wife or his girlfriend and and uh
two little darling children and had we
had dinner and he took me to see simon
and garfunkel at wembley stadium
wait a minute and you didn't even really
know him i didn't know him at all and
that was he just invited this wow
gave me food and tickets and you know
stuff and then we were shooting at um
uh pinewood and he he took me down to
the commissary and he said you just
start a tab for her here at the
commissary he's like i never went again
because you know
i bring my cheese and crackers from home
wow but um
he couldn't have been more generous and
sweet and then on the set and and so i
worked with him mostly as clark for like
weeks we did all the clark stuff right
and then i was coming to the set and i
was i was a superman
comic fanatic as a kid i would i would
trade the comic books i love wow
love i wasn't i wasn't a big superman
believe it look at me horror movies
yeah you know yeah
that's posters yeah anyway oh my god
so anyway so the first time i i go on
the set and i didn't see him because he
had a separate room for him when he was
doing um
spelling superman because he had a lot
of different makeup and wig and kind of
stuff he had to put on and so i didn't
see him and and i i knew i was going to
work with him as superman i'd seen on
screen as superman you know but i hadn't
so i'm walking by in the in the we're
going to this to the set and the stage
is really dark and i i hear this voice
say hello annette
and i look to my right and i i look at
this it was like looking up a mountain i
looked
like that and i not i'm not kidding i i
started to i
kind of like stutter and and and got
chills and just it was it was there was
superman it was dressed up he was in the
whole gear
and talking about it now i get chills
thinking about it wow it was amazing
because it was a thing from my childhood
and from watching movies and then from
knowing him but it was it was the first
time i really felt like
i don't know who that is he wasn't chris
reeve you know he was he was talking a
different way he had a totally different
kind of
energy about him
i don't think people realized what a
great actor he was he was a great i mean
somewhere in time is one of my favorite
movies yeah you know he could just
really turn it on he had this sweetness
this innate vulnerability to him right
oh he was wonderful god just wonderful
are you someone who gets
do you even think ahead of time like
this is going to be hit there's got to
be a hit right it's going to be a hit
it's going to be a lot i'm sure i've
done that a lot in my in my past but
then
how do you treat sort of like
when something comes out and it's not
great or it doesn't or it bombs or it
how do you deal with that stuff
it doesn't really affect me anymore it
may be early on it did i'd think oh this
is good but it
all i ever wanted was to continue to
work to do enough work where people knew
who i was and not repeat myself and and
i've been able to do that yeah so
and the
this is also why i don't watch what i do
because you don't watch what you do no
at all
it depends sometimes i do like i did um
i worked i did three episodes of kidding
with jim carrey and and frank langella
and i watched that because
i love frank langella
and i re and i i had missed an
opportunity to to work with him early on
in my career i just didn't get this part
i came down to me and somebody else the
other girl got it and i always regret it
i thought and so i got
just a couple years ago to work with him
on this thing and also to work with jim
carrey you know it's like so how was he
he was he was great he's very intense he
is everything yes
uh i don't know if he's always that way
or whether is this part but he's not the
big funny outlandish guy you meet he
this is he is when they take action
that's what we were also playing a very
i was playing his mother who had
alzheimer's and i was in a um a facility
that it was all in the 60s if you if
nobody's seen kidding you should watch
it it's it's two seasons of amazing work
by everybody awesome
i everybody you would love it yeah i
will watch it he plays a sort of mr
rogers type who's who's going through
this terrible crisis in his marriage and
then you've seen that well i've seen it
uh because uh my girlfriend is actually
she's a voice actress and she is uh this
tara lipinski's parakeet oh my gosh so
she does a lot of swearing as like a
parakeet there's like a scene where
that's amazing or jim carrey amanda
i'm gonna watch it it's a brilliant show
it's so sad it didn't continue on um but
you don't watch yourself though by the
way no no so i watch that but but i
don't i don't normally watch myself uh
if i want to see for some reason like a
little bit of it but i won't watch the
whole thing um because it's just it
it's never
what
because you don't have control of it
maybe you have maybe they picked a take
you didn't particularly feel good about
right or they cut it together in a way
that's like oh or you don't like the way
you look you don't like the way you look
yeah all these different things so it's
the doing of it i love doing it i love
getting up early and thinking about it
and being focused on it and doing it and
and and oh it's just it's like a puzzle
that is so different every time because
you you know all the elements are
different the director the in the
material and your co
actors and uh where you are if you're in
canada you know it's just
i just find it endlessly fascinating
because you can prepare and prepare but
once you get there it's always a little
bit different unpredictable yeah that's
what i love about it wow and that's why
i love being on on stage too because
then you have the the live element you
have the audience the response a part of
yeah such such a part of the show
that's amazing i mean i i know those
actors who that's their mentality i just
want to work yeah i just want to work
and do something and be on set and i go
i i don't
i don't want to be on any set i don't
want to work i want to make i want to do
everything i can to be on something that
i think people will watch and be like
what do you care if you're just acting
it's all about i go because i don't want
to be on a show that's not great why why
is that so bad i want to be on something
that's really good or i'd rather not act
it's not bad at all everybody but it's a
weird mentality that i have
i don't want to just i just look if i
knock on wood but if i was broke i would
do anything yeah i'd work at mcdonald's
i don't give a [ __ ] i'd go back to
working on go carts being a mechanic on
a go-kart track
but anyway i love that you that's how
you feel i love that that you just wake
up and go and how can i make this
interesting and you know what frustrates
you though about filming what because
there were times i'd say 99 of the time
you were always
very excited on set
but there were some points at the end
where i think you were like all right
yeah i'm kind of maybe a little over it
i was very i think we were all up you
know after a while well for me it was
weird see you guys were all there you
you stayed you lived there
there were times i'd go back three three
times a week
and like i would ask them each year i
would say is it possible
you know i go home on the weekends is it
possible for me to either have friday or
monday off my kids were in school there
were all these school events
and every year i'd ask them and every
year i'd be the last up friday night and
the first up monday morning
and it was like it just upset you it was
just like you have no
i you know it's all about the show it's
all about the schedule i know that was a
crazy schedule yeah i mean second unit i
never saw a second unit like that where
it was just as much big scenes being
done on three days
i know and i didn't have to be part of
that and i also
felt like well
if the show is short
my scene will be in
my little two three page scene will be
in and if it's long that'll be the first
thing cut because it was always written
that way towards the end and i just
thought
why am i here what's the point right i
mean i it was wonderful
money because now i
have enough money to do the theater that
i want to do yeah
it was great you know to be able to
provide for my family sorry i got it i
got a [ __ ] frog in my head oh there's
the fba there we go yes i coughed it out
yeah we could have edited it but i'm
gonna keep your [ __ ]
i'm gonna keep you [ __ ]
because i you know honestly
you had a blast i think for a lot of the
time it was just towards the end you
were just like okay
it was exhausting because
it wasn't interesting work i'll come and
do anything if it's interesting right
here's your coffee uh you know here's
here honey you know
michael always says what did you have to
say today oh clark how's your leg you
know whatever it was for some reason you
know tom loves you
loves you he adore tom he wanted he just
spent the night for a couple of nights
here we're talking about a new project
we're doing and
he's like i want to be a fournette and
i'm like well she's at 12. oh i have to
leave it at 8 30.
and he was really bummed but he always
loved working with you he remembers a
scene he always talks about a scene
where he wasn't even supposed to tear up
or cry and he got emotional because you
made him emotional you were so engaged
and so present in the moment that it got
him emotional he felt like well that's
great that's what actors need to do for
one another you have to be in it all the
time you were you were always there i
tried to be anyway i loved working with
glover and that was so much fun when we
were working together yeah you know and
we we come up on the plane together and
and go home usually together and
uh you know it was just it was it was a
fun time like the first few years were
really fun did you audition for it
no i i came in i thought you knew this
no i didn't know anything i i was doing
the huntress and so
i didn't know anything about it and the
huntress ended and i got this call from
my agent saying that they
wanted to replace martha kent it had
been shot
it was a woman named cynthia ryan right
wonderful actress so they sent me the
pilot i saw it
and i loved it because i'm the superman
fanatic yeah and i was i loved it and
then i was like oh my god i'm
[ __ ] because i uh i love this show and
now i have to go to vancouver for but i
never expected it to be
a hit show like that ever
and um when it was it was like oh my god
i've got to do this for six years the
people stop you in the streets ever yes
and throw their arms around me what and
say we love this show so much it's the
only show i can watch with my family my
family we're in terrible crisis about
all this other stuff but we sit down and
watch smallville together and that made
me so happy i thought then that's worth
it to me
to be to be a force for good because as
an actor you feel like oh i'm just you
know doing stuff that makes me happy and
it's vain and it's
what does it mean to people and it's
like
it means something to people and this
show i'm doing now is the same way i get
recognized from it all the time it's a
romantic
drama based on romance books it was the
first time netflix ever went into that
genre right and it has become it's the
fourth
most streamed
show in the world in the world really
yeah it's huge i got to watch this they
they well it's
you know it's it's may not be your cup
of tea it's very very romantic and slow
what are you saying no i'm saying
i can't be romantic you can't but you
like horror movies i mean i mean i i
watch i could watch anything if it's
good it's good it's very well if you're
in it i'll check it out i'm gonna watch
kidding for sure oh you've got watch
kitty it's beautifully produced written
acted by wonderful and tim matheson who
i've known for for 40 something years we
play opposite one another and
we have a great time um
and yeah we're gonna do another season
soon
they've announced it so i can say it
netflix is very want you to be very
careful what's the show it's called
virgin river virgin river and where can
they find it netflix on netflix yeah
well how do you like working for netflix
they're great really they're great they
they have writer first refusal on
everything i do so anytime i want to do
anything even a play i have to go you
have to ask them and ask them but
they're great they've never said no you
can't the only thing i think they would
not want me to do is is uh like a
another mini series on showtime or hbo
not that i've been asked right but um
you know that we conflict with them
where did you meet michael mccann i knew
michael for years and years because we
were you know young hollywood and we
were really yeah so how far back did you
know him i knew him when he was doing
laverne and shirley really yeah
but you were just friends you hadn't you
didn't look romantic at all we weren't
even really friends i was with bruno
kirby and for many years and michael was
married he got married very young and so
he his his wife susan um was never
she wasn't an actress she wasn't
involved she's very into her horses and
that kind of you know that world so uh
so he he when he was i saw him around he
was always on his own he was always um
you know kind of stag but i'd see him at
you know rob reiner's house at a party
and i was there because not because of
me because of bruno right so and we'd
see each other at um at uh screenings of
movies and stuff so i just saw him and i
always thought he was really cute i
loved lauren and shirley i thought those
guys were amazing and and brilliant and
hilarious and um and i saw him one time
i remember he was driving in the valley
and i was had just started living in the
valley and um
i saw him and he was with his son
and his son was about five at the time
and i remember we stopped at a light and
he was there and i was here and he he
looked over and i saw him and we saw
each other exactly the same time and his
face lit up
and i thought oh he remembers who i am
you know it was like that was really
nice it made me feel really good wow so
then i didn't see him for many many
years
and i was living in oregon in ashland
oregon
and i was asked to do a lifetime movie
called
final justice
and
ron silver was supposed to do it
wonderful actor ron silver and he
decided he'd played one too many sleazy
lawyers
so they asked michael mckeon to do it
and
the next time i saw him was in uh
portland oregon where we um
we
played the uh
um enemies adversaries and we just got
to know each other we were so you became
friends really good friends before you
actually went out yes yes we were i was
still living in oregon but i was on my
way back to la i was divorced had been
for a few years and uh but i needed to
come back to la because the girls were
were about to my daughters were about to
go into high school and into middle
school they're four years apart so uh
i just i needed to be back in la i
to to work i couldn't do it from oregon
anymore because i was now in the early
40s and it was just not working out
so um
so he was michael was in a relationship
and we just stayed in touch we will have
the same books and movies and music and
he'd call me say hey elvis costello's on
blah blah blah turn it on and it was
that kind of relationship when did he
call and say i'd like to take you to
dinner he called me
i had a little inkling right but we
would email one another right and
i asked him how his his girlfriend was
and he said she's in vancouver it's just
as well
oh i thought oh trouble in paradise and
did never thought anything about it i
never had no designs on him in that way
i didn't ever want to get married again
i didn't even want to be in a
relationship again i just wanted to get
back to la get my girls in school
my parents were we were coming too and
we were all going to be in los angeles
and i was going to
kind of start this new chapter of my
life
and uh
and so then he so after that little
email exchange
it was
i remember my daughter anna was had been
really sick she was just flew or
something and i had her in bed with me
she was like
nine i think ten
and um she was burning up and i wanted
to watch her so i had her in bed with me
so the phone rang like 11 o'clock at
night
and
it was him
and i said oh michael hi i i i'd love to
talk to you but but anna's really sick
and i'm i just can't talk right now
and he said oh
okay
um i'll call you can i call you tomorrow
i thought oh my god it's that call and i
i did the thing that you i've never seen
anybody else
do in life right when i see it in a
movie i think that's not real
i went into the bathroom because i
didn't want to wake her up she'd finally
gone to sleep and i did silence
screaming and jumping up and down
why because i knew i heard everything in
his voice i knew i would marry him i
knew that we would be together forever i
just knew it some would call that psycho
yeah but it's just science but it's a
dream like
but you it wasn't like you didn't know
him it wasn't like he met somebody to
bargain but that's the one no this is
someone you knew i knew him very well
because i worked with him i worked with
him and i knew how he was in that in
that because you know the actor world
yeah you know to stay away well
you haven't always stayed away no no you
didn't stay away this time no no no no
so our first date was going to a
uh bob dylan van morrison joni mitchell
concert they were on tour together going
through all we saw him at ucla help me i
think i'm falling
she lived right well she lived close to
me
anyway she was it was a fantastic night
and um
we
ended well we knew we both knew
when we were both
van mark morrison was singing have i
told you lately which is our song uh and
we were just holding one another
weeping
weeping
because it was like this moment of this
our lives have completely came out of
the blue for both of us
we weren't looking for it it just
happened and we needed each other we
really did
and it's been so much fun it's how many
years now
it'll be 23 years married in march but
we've been together 25.
was there a little star struck you to
him him to you at all or was there any
because he just was kind of like no like
oh my god he was in spinal tap oh my god
he was laverne
and she was in this i hadn't seen
spider-man you hadn't seen this because
bruno was in spinal tap and that right
when we were breaking up was when he was
doing spinal taps so for me spinal tap
was like you know i just didn't want to
see it and then it got became so popular
that i had like well i don't want to say
you know
and then you ended up singing with the
band yeah i sing with a man and of
course now it's you know i i realize how
great it is and i even think bruno is
great in it which he is um
so but but you know it was mostly
because uh i just thought he was such a
brilliant
guy in general the way he would talk
about everything he knows
you know he's a celebrity jeopardy
champion he won a million dollars for a
multiple myeloma uh foundation he's he's
he's incredibly smart yeah he's also
very intimidating i worked with him on
smallville and i loved him but i was
also i remember when i don't know if you
care you talk about you smoke pot still
right him well you i i don't you don't
he does yeah but i remember smoking pot
with him in a hotel room you were there
yeah you're playing guitar
and i got really high i mean he must
have gave me some really good weed and i
got paranoid and i thought i was making
an ass to myself so i kind of left early
and i go oh my god i just blew it mccain
thinks i'm a dud no he loves you
that's how i thought no he's
intimidating he's really good he's
really i think he's just intense because
he's always serious about the role he
wants to nail the role he wants to do so
he's like that and that's what it was
about it wasn't about you know what i
mean but i loved it i loved it but i
always adored him tell me the story
quickly about it's 9 11 that's one of
the worst time time moments in u.s
history yeah and uh
you were trying to you had to go back to
well i was i i'd flown up on 910 uh to
to do second unit on the second episode
the one with dan lauria the football
right right yeah and so uh
the next morning all hell broke list the
world completely turned upside down so i
was there and all day i was waiting to
be called to the set finally got called
to the set and they came to the to the
door of my dressing room and said uh
we're not gonna get to you sorry
and i burst into tears another thing
that when they say on the page the she
bursts into tears i never really known
how to do that until that day when i
burst into tears in front of the poorest
sarah the pa i remember sarah yeah
yeah it's very sweet
so i burst into tears and then it didn't
look like they were gonna get to it any
time soon so i called the office bob yep
guy and said i would like to go home
because i was away from my family and i
was
i thought well they're going to hit la
if they're going to hit la i want to be
home yeah so i just wanted to get home
this is i said if you're not going to
need me i'm going home there are no
flights so i took the car that i had
been renting and i drove home and i
stopped in reading that was my only stop
and i got home they called and they said
we need you tomorrow.
i said you told me i could go home i was
like weeping i said i
why and then they said well if you're
not here we're going to s
that kind of stuff they started getting
really nasty about it and so i said well
i'll i'll i can't get there tomorrow
because i can't get a plane unless you
want to charter a flight for me
so i'm so mad
so michael said i'm coming with you so i
turned around the next morning we left
and drove drove all the way back
so somewhere between portland and
seattle i got this this weird melody in
my head
it kept going over and over and over in
my head finally i said mile do i am i
making this up or is this a song an old
song that he said
oh
i've never heard you you're making that
up he said let's put let's put lyrics to
it so we just said mommy and potatoes in
the paddy wagon and i said okay but
potato has to be a girl it can't be just
potatoes oh okay and we wrote the whole
song in the car on the drive in the car
and we had nothing nothing's going to
happen with this nothing's going to
happen so we get get there and we finish
the song in fact i think i went to work
the next morning and he finished
filling it all in
and like
he didn't have he must have brought his
guitar he brought his guitar because he
always yes he had his guitar so he was
fooling around with it figuring it out
and he said you know i think chris will
might like this for a mighty win chris
chris guest because they were in the
process of writing all the songs for the
movie
so
uh
we we did we wrote that and then we we i
can't remember the
timeline but anyway chris asked michael
to write if he wanted to write this
signature song for mitch and mickey and
he said the only thing it has to have a
kiss in it there's a kiss they whether
they're going to kiss or not the end of
the rainbow and so michael said to me do
you want to write this song with me i
have a title already
kiss a kiss at the end of the rainbow i
said yeah
so i drank two glasses of wine that
night
he dressed
he smoked his
his friend
and we sat down and we wrote it we we
mostly wrote the song and then we took
jimmy our beloved dog jimmy out for a
walk and finished writing the song
and then
took it to chris sang it for chris and
he said oh
it's beautiful but it's too it's it's a
real song it's it's too it's not
he didn't think it was going to be funny
enough
so we went home and wrote another song
called closer than tomorrow which is
another wonderful song but jamie lee
curtis happened to be there when we sang
it she said oh no that's the song it
should be a wonderful song it shouldn't
be funny it shouldn't it should be a
real love song
and we love that song because it's just
about us it's about our story and just
kind of how we we feel about one another
and um
it it and we were nominated for an
academy award for a while i mean come on
really crazy come on because of all the
and that score should have been
nominated every song
chris wanted every song to be a
different type of folk song right and
that's what they did you know they and
eugene and catherine wrote stuff and uh
cj vanston who's the the spinal tap guy
who does all their music for all their
movies um and traveled with them and
unwicked unplugged
he wrote a c shanty and didn't have
lyrics so michael and i wrote the lyrics
for that jesus so i had three songs
represented three songs and you had
never written a song before really i'd
written stuff for the kids just stupid
yeah stuff yeah so then i started
writing in earnest i started writing a
lot of a lot of songs and we were going
to write a musical together which
you know is never going to happen
because it's just too hard as
christopher guest intimidating
he used to be to me just
because of what you say he's just so
brilliant and you you just think so much
of his work and his
his amazing
you know these these stories which are
so sweet but when you look at the movies
that's what he's like
he's very sweet
you know he has a goodness about him
yeah that is not apparent because he's
he doesn't show it
very much but he's he's a lovely man and
um yeah
um i forgot the the nose this we're
going to do this last segment it's
really quick it's rapid fire oh god this
is called [ __ ] talking with the neto
tool okay and these are from patrons
lovable patrons they're on my patreon
they support the podcast in many ways
leanne what was it like having your
husband portray perry white on
smallville i noticed the two of you did
not have a lot of screen time together
during that episode we had a wonderful
time it was just nice to have him up
there with me and being paid to be up
there with me being my fancy man um yeah
we didn't have a lot to do on set
together but later on we did there was
they called us both back for uh for an
episode you know after my my first stint
and uh any time i'm with michael off on
screen i'm very happy
awesome
rozzy my question is what is the
funniest thing that you have seen happen
on the set of a smallville on the set of
smallville
um gosh the first thing that comes to my
mind no this is that funny my daughter
anna uh came up and was a cheerleader in
the in the episode where they were doing
a lot of cheerleading right so i just
remember being out there with her and
you know i'm sort of the stage mom like
oh is she okay or she because she wasn't
really supposed to be there she's not
canadian she wasn't really you know
working like but she's featured that
they were very sweet about featuring her
and she did a really good job but she
was in the sun and she didn't have
sunblock on and i was very concerned
about her her white
skin very pale skin well she's very
easily burned
so no that's not funny
funny
god i'm so it was it rozzy what's that
rozzy rozzy i'm i want to think of
something funny oh my gosh i mean i had
to have made you laugh
i'm sure i just made you laugh you made
me laugh
about nonsense that's okay okay lisa h
yes well no emily s what is it like
filming on it such a classic movie one
of my favorites i had the little series
maybe the next to doing crossed my heart
with with uh marty short because i did
nothing but laugh on that show um it was
close to that because it had all these
guys i was the only girl was like going
to summer camp i never went to summer
camp in my real life but it was what i
imagined but they were all like vying
for my attention and they were all
really brilliant funny guys um i'd known
john and richard thomas um
forever and
we just we just had a ball even tim
curry i mean because
out of out of pennywise you know he's
just one of us it was really fun so he
would talk to you guys and like he
wasn't too serious going hello no
no no no god no we all go out to dinner
together we went dancing that was kind
of our bonding moment to to be this
group of people together yeah kristen k
yes not kristen croup
uh will your character hope be returning
to virgin river the answer is the answer
is yes for season four season four and
then we go start season five sometime
later this year i don't know when this
is a little complicated question i don't
know if you could do a rapid fire but
maya p over your career how have you
seen female roles if roles evolve and
what would you like to still see what
would you still like to see female roles
evolve i like that you know it's funny
because i like the idea that women are
being these kind of badass you know
running around this this movie i don't
know the name of it that um actress i
love mary elizabeth winstead
did where she's this now she's a hit
woman or she's something like that i
love the idea of it but when i see the
trailer i don't want to see it i just i
it's not that i want her to be a girl i
want her to do what guys do but i don't
like movies like that at all i guess
maybe that's my thing i'm not a big guy
yeah but but uh i love that uh
i love um
i love movies made by women this power
of the dog jane campion's new phone i
got to see it
it's so great and i didn't like spencer
bored as [ __ ]
i don't ever like to say
not good things about things right it's
like i just i just don't say thank you i
can't not well it's good it's good i
wish i were more uh i'm not terrible i
just was born i'm honest at home but i i
listen i think she did a very good job
a very good job
um i i love her i think she's fantastic
i love her i love her very much and i
you know i really love scarlett
johansson oh yeah i agree
i think she's such a good actor i i hope
i answered the question about women's
roles i you know i i can't i can only
really speak for myself yeah no quickly
how is nick nolte to work with i love
nikki you love nick noel
i love nolte favorite line in 48 hours
is when he's with eddie murphy and eddie
murphy's soon because jack tell me a
story he's like [ __ ] you convict he's
like oh that's one of my favorites
remember that i vaguely remember it
because i only saw it once when it first
came out um
i love nick nolte i had a wonderful time
with him and i i saw him a few years ago
and and we had a nice how are you nice
big hug uh
working with barry manilow did you sing
with barry yes what did you sing i was
lola you were lola yeah so you sing all
these songs i sang man wanted
which is this wonderful song yeah and uh
he was mostly him singing i got to sing
abba dabba honeymoo abba dabba dabba
dabba dabba dabba i said the monkey too
though chimp um because we our
characters meet by going on like name
that tune or something and so i i say
something wrong i say abbott
i said the monkey to the shrimp and so i
get kicked off then i faint because i
haven't eaten then he wins the contest
and he takes me out to dinner or
something then we decided we're gonna
audition for the copacabana show and was
he great he was fantastic barry manilow
she worked with barry manilow i did i
loved him i see this is the unlike this
pollyanna i love pretty much everybody
no it's good you're that's why people
like working with you that's why you you
know well i just appreciate them
everybody works so hard and everybody's
very different and i i just enjoy what i
do well i love you being here
thank you for answering all my questions
absolutely this has been really fun for
me me too i found out a lot about you
that i didn't really know oh good you
know what i mean sometimes you have to
put the headphones on and you have to
zone in and go holy [ __ ] man annette
look at this oh well thank you for
having me back i haven't been here in so
many years and so it's i'm very happy to
be back well guys watch virgin river
season four netflix i'm gonna watch it
so you should and i'm also gonna watch
that uh kidding yes i really gotta watch
this kidding is wonderful and cause
amanda's the voice of the parrot if you
wanna hear a paraguay drop some our
c-bombs then yeah sweet
uh
thank you annette for allowing me to be
inside of you and um you will call james
remar and talk to michael
i will have to find his he changed his
email address so i have to track him
down somewhere i have somebody else who
knows him real who asked me about him
coming on the podcast because i just
love him i'll find him he's awesome he's
awesome all right i love you love you
too bye
i loved talking to her um it was it was
groovy having her over the house um i
hadn't seen her in a long time i thought
she looked great yeah and uh she was
really sweet just a nice little nice
person nice disposition yeah nice
uh demeanor yeah
uh
yeah yeah yeah just she's really
friendly she's really friendly i really
liked it i hope you liked the podcast
today i hope you uh thank you for
listening thank you for taking the time
to listen um i'm about to read the top
tier patrons uh also reminding me if you
want to get any cool merch signed
autographs lex luthor or sign stuff
tumblers
mugs from the podcast go to the inside
of you online store
if you want band stuff go to
sunspin.com get your sunspin hat
get your sunspin mug
pictures cds albums all that stuff
and um and if you want to join patreon
to support the podcast go to patreon.com
inside you i will write you a message
as soon as i see your message
so i thank you we're going to read the
top tier patrons ryan okay are you ready
for this let's do it uh we'll blitz
through them nancy d leah sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e brian h nico p robert
b jason w kristen k did i tell you we
have new inside of you socks
available what's on the inside of your
online store well we do inside of you
online socks folks if you want some
socks go to that inside of you online
store
raj c hi raj joshua d cjp jennifer n
stacy l jamal f janelle b kimberly e
mike eldon supremo 99 more ramira san
diego m chad w
leanne p myopia matty s belinda
n correct chris h dave h chila g brad d
ray h tap of the t tommen liliana a
talia m betsy d chad l rochelle marion
meg k trav l dan
the man n all right big stevie w angel
uh
of mine angel of m well m angel of ammo
oh great mine rhiannon c cory k super
sam dev nixon you got it dev nixon
what's up dev nixon it's super sam
michelle a jeremy c andy t cody r
gavinator david c
john b
brandy d ivor camille asked the c joey m
willie f david h omri design otg eugene
and leah chris p nikki g cory nicole
patricia heather l jake b james b
bobbitt joshua b
uh tony g megan t mel s
orlando c john b caroline r rob e paul c
christine s sarah s eric h spring
jennifer r shane r m r mark m and jeremy
v
jeremy it's a funny way of spelling it
g-a-e-r-a-m-i-e
oh that's fun jeremy spoken
uh yeah hey guys without you guys on the
patreon i i really couldn't uh do the
show you helped the podcast more than
you possibly know and thank you and
those of you who want to join patreon
and get your name shouted out
join it
patreon.com inside you
this has been a real treat having an edo
2 on the show last week we had jared
padilecki i think the shows are getting
better and better i hope you stay tuned
i hope you stick around i'm trying to
stick around but i need you to help me
stick around so
keep motivating me keep appreciating the
show
keep sending kind messages keep uh
spreading the word and uh most
importantly be good to yourselves damn
it be good to yourselves and uh i hope
you have a lovely week from myself
michael rosenbaum here in the hollywood
hills of california
varietals out here to the god of what
girls got hood
we lose our minds sometimes sometimes i
think i'm losing my mind this time this
time i'm losing my mind you know that is
no beastie boys
really yeah beastie boys
guys uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you it's
a real treat
uh
you know it's it's really cool when your
colleagues are talking about how much
they like your show and uh fans come up
to you and just listeners not even fans
listeners people who listen to the show
and uh it keeps me motivated it really
does so thank you again and uh again be
good to yourselves i'll see you next
week all
bye
[Music]